[Music]
on this Monday night the fight to keep
families together the plan to get
Canadian citizens out of China but what
about permanent residents
please don't split up families plus how
the economic consequences are worse than
SARS emergency in the sky the Air Canada
flight forced to make an impromptu
landing Iowa's raucous caucus
I think caucus site is going to be
absolutely crazy voting for a Democratic
candidate to take on Donald Trump
Jackson prosecco is in Des Moines
tonight Plus should the monarchy keep
calm and carry on you need to always
stay relevant
Canadians reflect on the Royals after
Harry and Megan's big departure
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight Robin Gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with promising news for hundreds
of Canadians stranded at the center of
China's coronavirus outbreak the federal
government says it's making progress on
an evacuation plan and it's working to
make sure families aren't separated a
number of other countries including
Germany the US and the UK have already
airlifted citizens out of the outbreak
zone when Canadians will be airlifted
remains unclear our government says it's
still waiting for Chinese approval
meanwhile the novel coronavirus outbreak
continues to spread the number of cases
continues to soar tonight with more than
20,000 reported around the world the
death toll is also rising it's now at
426 in our top story tonight Michael
Couture reports on the growing concerns
among Canadians in the outbreak zone but
please hurry and please yeah please
don't split up families an emotional
plea from a stranded mother Meighan
Millward is trying to get home to
montreal with her husband and two kids
she and the children are Canadian
citizens so they should be guaranteed
seats on an evacuation flight but it's
unclear if her husband who has permanent
resident status will be left behind in
Hebei China I mean I don't know what I'm
gonna do on my own with two kids in
quarantine for 14 days at a media
briefing Foreign Affairs Minister
Francois Philip champagne tried to
reassure stranded Canadians that
families wouldn't be split up we have
asked the Chinese authority to allow the
primary caregivers whether they're
Canadian citizen permanent resident or
Chinese national to be able to fly with
that child in Canada we receive
assurance that China will follow suit on
that
so if mil words husband isn't considered
the primary caregiver will they split up
the family
well that is still unclear do you know
the government has a plane and up
more than 300 Canadians who want to come
back it will be pre-positioned in
Vietnam while waiting for China to give
the green light to land in Wuhan we're
working hard with Chinese authorities in
terms of bringing people home as quickly
as we can you understand there are many
steps both health and safety steps to be
made into it that have to be gone
through one of those steps is the
Chinese approval of the flight manifest
list so those Canadians will be allowed
through police checkpoints in the city
which is under a lockdown
what's back in Canada they'll be
quarantined for 14 days at CFB Trenton
in Ontario passengers will be isolated
from residents of the base and each
other so if one person falls ill that
won't ruin SSI Tate the start of an
entire another quarantine for all of the
passengers for now the Canadian
government is telling people to avoid
non-essential travel to China but the
Canadian military issued a travel ban in
an order to Canadian Forces members on
Monday the country's top soldier general
Jonathan Vance told soldiers to cancel
any travel to or through China
Vance's order said it's too much of a
health risk to the military's readiness
capabilities Robin Mike look at or in
Ottawa as Mike mentioned Canada is still
waiting for China to approve the
evacuation plan when that happens a
number of steps are in place to help
prevent any potential spread of the
virus every passenger will be screened
by both Chinese and Canadian authorities
before boarding the plane in China
during the flight passengers will be
monitored by Canadian Forces medical
team if they become ill they will be
moved to an isolated area of the plane
and treated when the plane lands at CFB
Trenton in Ontario all travelers will be
again screened they will then remain at
the base for 14 days to ensure they are
clear of the virus back at the center of
the outbreak a massive new hospital is
up and running after being built in just
over a week over the last 10 days
cameras have been rolling as
construction crews work around the clock
to build the thousand bed facility
authorities had ordered the project to
help deal with Wuhan
severe hospital bed shortage the
facility will reportedly focus on
treating people infected with the new
corona virus as you saw there the
Chinese government is working fast to
try to contain the outbreak but as Eric
Swanson explains those efforts are doing
little to ease growing economic concerns
in parts of China drones equipped with
audio messages are telling Chinese
citizens not to gather in public about
llamas while going home this woman is
being told to go home and rest and off
she goes
China's high-tech and low-tech capacity
to impose order is being tested from the
remarkably Swift construction of new
hospitals to Chinese officials telling
people not to go outside the country is
desperately trying to contain the spread
of the corona virus it's asking the
world for more protective medical gear
but it's also trying to contain the
message of fear China is navigating
between greater openness while urging
the international community not to
overreact the World Health Organization
is helping with that message if we
invest in fighting at the epicenter at
the source then the spread to other
countries is minimal and also slow the
spread of the novel coronavirus looks
alarming cases have now been reported in
25 countries but the epicenter remains
in China as of this afternoon there were
more than 17 thousand cases in China
including Hong Kong and Macau but in the
rest of the world only about a hundred
and sixty cases the number of deaths
paints a picture far less alarming
except for China deaths there 361 about
95 percent in central Hubei Province
outside China only one death reported in
the Philippines the numbers are rising
but as of this afternoon China remains
the one global hotspot empty streets
show a serious response in China but
also signal a sharp downturn in the
country's economy coming off a Lunar New
Year holiday the Chinese stock market
plunged 8% China is now such an integral
part of the International economy that
global economic growth is forecast to
drop 0.2%
father the epidemic has a growing impact
on the economy says this Chinese
official but he adds we are completely
confident to win the battle controlling
this disease but many countries are
taking no chances Indonesia has stopped
flights to and from China Hong Kong has
now closed all but three border
crossings to mainland China from
Australia to Belgium quarantines are
being established it is a balancing act
for China and the world responds swiftly
and with urgency but without stoking so
much fear that it could harm the global
economy more than necessary
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto dozens
of cases are being confirmed each day
and the virus is classified as an
epidemic but it could become a pandemic
I'll tell you what that would mean at
Global News dossier / global national an
Air Canada flight bound for Toronto had
to make an emergency landing pilots were
forced to turn back to Madrid when the
plane suffered an engine issue shortly
after takeoff it was a nervous ride for
passengers they spent more than four
hours in their seats as the plane
circled the skies to lighten the load
and as Redman Shannon reports the
Spanish military had to get involved
this is the perfect landing that brought
to an end an anxious afternoon for the
136 people on board Air Canada flight
837 just after takeoff a loud bang was
heard on board and one passenger filmed
this flame out from the left-hand engine
Air Canada says a tire on one of the
aircraft's ten wheels burst after
takeoff the same passenger tweeted that
this was the cause of the engine issue
commercial aircraft like the Boeing 767
are designed to fly safely on one engine
but like most passenger planes they
can't land on a full tank of fuel that
is why the aircraft had to spend four
and a half hours circling to burn off
the weight rather than dumping the fuel
it's not an emergency dire emergency
rather the only time you have to hurry
in an aircraft is when the airplane is
on fire or you're running out of fuel
but the situation was serious enough for
the Spanish Air Force to scramble an
f-18 to escort the plane and inspect for
an e damage just after dark the plane
was finally ready to land safely much to
the relief of everyone on board this
photo appears to show a burst tire on
the main landing gear many of the
Canadian passengers were brought to a
hotel to wait until the next available
seats to Toronto Redmond Shannon Global
News London
Iran has stopped cooperating with
Ukraine in the investigation into the
downing of a passenger jet last month
that killed a hundred and seventy-six
people including 57 Canadians a
Ukrainian TV outlet broadcast leaked
audio that suggests Iran knew
immediately the plane had been shot down
something the Iranian government
initially denied the audio reportedly
captures the voice of an Iranian pilot
on another plane alerting air traffic
controllers about a light in the sky
that looked like a missile
[Laughter]
moments later he reported seeing an
explosion Ukraine International Airlines
flight 752 was hit by two missiles
shortly after taking off from Tehran
International Airport it was headed to
keeve but crashed into a field outside
Tehran Iran is still in possession of
the planes black boxes and once the data
recorders to be analyzed in that country
Britain is introducing emergency
legislation to stop convicted terrorists
from being automatically released after
serving half their sentence yesterday a
suspect attacked two people with the
machete less than two weeks after
getting out of jail and as crystal
commencing reports he had a history of
radical views moments of panic and chaos
captured by witnesses for the second
time in just three months a convicted
terrorists went on a rampage injuring
innocent people but for the brilliance
of the medics but for the speed of the
police we could have been talking about
a far far worse incident yesterday
Sudesh Amon stabbed two people a third
was injured by debris when police opened
fire killing the 20 year olds it was
absolutely horrible and they were just
screaming and screaming and I looked at
the distance I could notice that some
lady was on the floor as may be sitting
just I think just after the leaders
supermarket I did not want to walk down
there because I just don't have that
image in my head
this attack was unusual in that it was
determined almost immediately to have
been terrorism related Amon was under
active surveillance with
counterterrorism officials ordering the
officers tailing him to be armed his
mother told england's Sky News that he
was a polite boy and that he was further
radicalized while in prison there are
just over 200 people in prison and
Britain convicted of terrorism offences
Amon was released just halfway through
his three years
he pleaded guilty to possessing and
distributing terrorist materials the
government is now vowing to end early
releases and possibly increase maximum
sentences for terrorism offences the
Prime Minister frustrated said there are
no easy solutions why was there no
system of scrutiny and a parole system
to check whether he was really a
suitable candidate for automatic early
release people here fear another attack
one where police may not be close at
hand
Christel the Manson Global News London
it's the first test for the Democrats
who want to be President
coming up the Iowa caucuses kick off and
we're there
voters in Iowa are having their say in
who should be the next Democratic
presidential nominee the Hawkeye State
is the first stop in a long primary
season that will set the stage for the
election the frontrunners after
tonight's caucuses will have a leg up in
this race but it may be a while yet
before Democrats know who will take on
Donald Trump in November our Jackson
prosecco is watching it all in Iowa
tonight Jackson how's it going there
well Robin this is the scene playing out
in schools and libraries and even living
rooms across the state tonight as people
move to various corners of various
different sized rooms to signal their
intent to support a different candidate
but at this early hour in this highly
contested election year it's hard to say
who's going to emerge as the winner
tonight we're gonna have the largest
turnout hopefully for Bernie that we've
ever seen the final push in the first in
the nation states they're just saying
thanks everybody as Democratic
presidential candidates rally supporters
ahead of the most uncertain Iowa
caucuses in a generation our number one
job is to beat Donald Trump women win
let's get this done they're all hoping
for a breakout moment but the top for
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden Pete Budaj edge
and Elizabeth Warren are stuck in a dead
heat are you outside a high school in
Des Moines Democrats lined up for blocks
to hear from Budaj edge the party's
young rising star we cannot take the
risk of meeting a fundamentally new
challenge by falling back on the
familiar we can't be afraid of moving to
the future
beneath the excitement is nervousness
about who the best candidate is to take
on Donald Trump in November
like Biden
when they take a risk like Obama we win
but the party remains torn between a
shift to the left or staying put with a
safe candidate in the center that has
led to a large number of undecided
caucus goers even right up to the last
minute the safe choice is Joe Biden
Barack Obama's vice president reason
that run is because I have experience
he pulls ahead of Trump e'en
state-to-state matchups and has broad
support he's the president for right now
because we really need to unite more and
not you know fall into the divisive
nasaan either side of the aisle we are
down to the wire
untie me but Bernie Sanders and his
dedicated supporters could upend all
that if the turnout is high
the Vermont senator is polling high
enough to make some Democrats very
nervous while others see the deep divide
as a sign of a healthy party Bernie have
so many great choices we have I mean to
me whoever gets the nomination we're
going to totally support
already sensing that this could be a
late night with results that perhaps
don't go their way some of the campaigns
are already spinning suggesting that
what happens here in Iowa maybe doesn't
matter all that much Robin but Jackson
time and time again we hear that the
Iowa caucuses do matter so how will the
results be used by the candidates
tonight well it's all about signalling
who's got the momentum who's got the
organizational power to continue their
way to winning the presidential
nomination and the bottom line is that
no matter what unfolds here in Iowa
tonight it's a pretty good predictor
historically speaking the winner has
gone on to win the nomination all right
Jackson prosecco in Iowa tonight
closing arguments have wrapped up in
president Trump's impeachment trial an
acquittal is all but certain
the president's lawyers say the
Democrats have been trying to oust Trump
from office since his inauguration in
2017 and the Democrats are fighting back
can we be confident that he will not
continue to try to cheat in that very
election can we be confident that
Americans and not foreign powers will
get to decide and that the president was
shun any further foreign interference in
our democratic affairs and the short
plain sad incontestable answer is no you
can't the trial is adjourned until
Wednesday when senators will cast their
votes on Tuesday night Trump will
address Americans in the State of the
Union address Republicans are
encouraging him to avoid talking about
the impeachment trial in his speech
still ahead the locust infestation in
East Africa that's only getting bigger
beauty
the UN is warning that billions of
locusts already ravaging countries in
East Africa could infest more nations in
the region and the world body is calling
for 76 million dollars in aid to combat
the crisis the vast swarms have
decimated food production in Kenya
Somalia and Ethiopia
experts warn their numbers may grow 500
times Kenya is trying to use pesticides
to stop the spread hundreds of people
stranded at a BC ski resort are slowly
making their way off the mountain crews
temporarily opened a road to one-way
traffic today from Sasquatch mountain
east of Vancouver
they've been stranded since Friday when
a landslide took out a section of the
only Road in and out of the area today
drivers had to follow a pilot vehicle to
safely get through the mud and debris
others have paid for a helicopter lift
crews say it could take nearly a week to
clean up the mess one of the biggest
telecom tycoons convicted of fraud has
died just weeks after getting early
release from prison Canadian born Bernie
Evers became one of America's richest
people after starting WorldCom it was
one of the world's largest
telecommunications companies in 2002 it
went bust over an accounting scandal at
the time the bankruptcy was the largest
in US history Evers was found guilty of
securities fraud in 2005 and sentenced
to 25 years in prison but this past
December a judge set him free citing
health problems Burnie Evers was 78
up next the divided Canadian viewpoints
on the monarchy's future
this week queen elizabeth ii will
celebrate 68 years on the throne
she is the longest reigning living
monarch and she's more popular among
Canadians than ever but the heirs to the
throne not so much a rocky start to 2020
has put the future of the Royal role in
question just simple reports for queen
elizabeth ii the new year brings new
challenges this marks her first public
engagement of 2020 and her first since
brexit megan and harry's controversial
decision to retire from royal life and
move part-time to canada but even in the
face of adversity Her Majesty's
unparalleled propensity for keeping calm
and carrying on has made her more
popular than ever the Queen has a very
strong brand personally she's out
polling the monarchy in a lot of ways a
nips us poll conducted for Global News
finds around 81% of Canadians agree the
Queen has done a good job as monarch but
the same poll found that without the
Queen Canadians are divided around half
want Canada's formal ties to the
monarchy to end whence her reign is over
when people think about what's gonna
happen after she's gone we're gonna have
a national debate in this country
because there is a divided opinion the
Royal Family's second most popular
member is Harry the ipsus poll finds
Canadians support his decision to step
back from the spotlight as long as
taxpayers don't pay his security bill I
think that opens up a whole a whole
range of opportunities for for the
monarchy when it comes to this country
but Harry's departure also provides
fodder for those fighting to end the
monarchy the Royals are basically
trained seals that are designed to
perform for our entertainment and that
must be a terrible life
Prince William and Kate meanwhile have
sought to balance royal duties with
being hands-on parents to young children
so we're seeing fewer working members of
the royal family at the same time that
senior members the royal family are also
looking for some semblance of work-life
balance so that's going to be a
challenge going forward
this royal historian predicts a smaller
less visible royal family moving forward
and as she marks 68 years on the throne
this week the head of the family remains
as integral as ever
Geoff sample Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
North Sydney in Cape Breton Nova Scotia
thank you for watching and have a great
night
[Music]